thought I would forever be a doctor I
thought that was my path I always like
to say I was kind of Korean Din to
stayin premed
[Music]
knocked up I remember I put myself on
tape and judd apatow the writer director
was looking for an actor with medical
experience so I remember putting myself
on tape for knocked up and I didn't hear
for three months so I figured I didn't
get the role and then I got a call three
months later from one of judge producers
saying that you're in the running you're
in the mix but we're actually about to
start production right now and while
we're making decision on your character
we're inviting you to do a table read
and it was a table read with the full
cast like Seth Rogen it was Adam Scott
it was Jonah Hill Jason Segel Craig
Robinson it's I mean that movie knocked
up had everybody I call it The Avengers
of comedy you know it literally anybody
who's anybody in today's comedy was was
in that movie so it was really like the
the maybe the most pressure filled
audition of my life like maybe five days
later I got the part
I actually prepared pretty extensively
for that role I mean I modeled it after
a few a few doctors I didn't
particularly care for and I worked with
in the past in a doctor-patient
relationship to be healthy
one should not ask the doctor too many
questions
got that bad you're not the star who was
a star of this show among the three of
us the patient I actually I think I
wrote some of those doctors names on the
script I can recall and it just kind of
locked me in and it was a bit of medical
authenticity plus my first real
experience into actor prep you know and
really kind of kind of getting into the
skin of that character is still one of
my favorite performances to this day
Judd Apatow he I mean he's one of most
amazing directors I've ever worked with
he spoils you he spoils the actors
because he really does
let the talent play judge notice that on
uncertain takes he would just see me
like go out a comedy go out of take
really hard
and then gel would be like okay that's a
little too strong but and then he
actually he said to himself like you
know wow he he's bringing I didn't know
he could do that sort of comedy I wasn't
looking for him to do that kind of
comedy in this movie and after a while
he just uh he said Ken you know we got
10 minutes left to tape of a film just
do whatever you want and that became its
own DVD feature and you see me just
going unhinged it's called Cooney gone
wild
it's like Lily five minutes and 46
seconds of just just like Cooney yelling
at Seth Rogen and Katherine Heigl and
Adam Scott who played my nurse and to
serve and protect non malfeasance [ __ ]
we're gonna have a good time okay like a
u2 concert okay all right I'm gonna take
a big fat nap now because he called me
it was still one of the highlights of my
career and even getting applause by the
set at the end it's just yeah the more I
yeah Wow that I hadn't thought about
that a while the office it was his name
was Bill and he was in Michael Scott's
improv group and the director was Paul
Feig but I remember that was a big fan
of the BBC office big fan of Ricky
Gervais zhe's version of the you know
the original version of The Office and
that time when I auditioned for the
American office it was not necessarily a
hit at that time and it kind of begat it
became a hit very slowly and and I was
one of the few people that really got
the tone of that show just from the
get-go so when I auditioned I heard
every line and I would look directly to
camera just kind of steal a glance I
remember stealing a couple of subtle
glances and I remember Paul Feig
laughing so hard at the softest things
Michael what did you tell him nothing
then why are his hands up bill
he told me he couldn't show it to me but
he has a gun steve carell he's one of my
favorite actors of all time he's he's
he's a huge influence on me whether I
mean known Steve now for a few years he
part doesn't want to hear that from a
Perry so modesty I know
actually no he doesn't want to hear
stuff like I mean he'll probably watch
that me saying that right now me like oh
come on Ken come on Mandy epic so he's
that like modest about it but he it
really was in basketball terms oh it was
it's like working with LeBron man you're
just working with just one of the
all-time greats and to improvise during
an improv class what they were doing was
next-level stuff some of Steve's friends
from second city that you know of his
class at Second City there were also
guest stars on the show and they had
this rapport in this chemistry he's very
angry midgets boom please Michaels goon
FBI you know you did they were putting
on a master class of improv comedy
acting and to this day I don't think
I've ever seen anything like that it was
kind of masters at work and I just had
like the best seat in the house
role models role models is maybe my
favorite movie that enough people don't
mention you know it would I did that
movie soon after knocked up and I did a
lot of research for that role I don't
know anything about LARPing or
live-action role-playing or any of those
things so I went to a few events in
Malibu and just studied it take some
pride and dying in horrible death but I
killed you can't kill me after I already
killed you davit bling cracking yes my
liege this he slay me he does not slay
the King got to a point I knew so much
about live-action roleplay
I was started improvising in LARP speak
and because I played the king of this
whole village or of this whole country
of Casa Dona
to be wounded shall I take him out sire
nay this one is mine I kind of stole a
little bit of mr. Chow mousse from the
King because I did those movies like
like like right after one another yeah
the hangover trilogy the movie that made
me a made man hanging over it it changed
you know it's it's my Sergeant Pepper
you know it changed my life from black
and white to Technicolor it just it just
changed everything I've knocked up open
the door for me in the business The
Hangover just burst it wide open and I
went from you know as a pretty anonymous
character actor to a guy of us just for
the rest of my life I'll be forever
known as mr. Chau no matter what I do
I'll be forever known and I don't mind
because still I don't think I'll ever
play a light just kind of just
gut-busting hilarious character I don't
think I'll ever I don't think I ever
play a character just balls-out funnier
literally balls-out funnier character
than mr. Chau yeah it it was kind of
lightning in a bottle it was actually
people don't know this it was actually
written for a 60 year old man and and I
remember thinking to myself well hey I'm
not gonna get the part so but when the
audition 99% of auditioning of acting is
getting rejected and that's just the
name of the game but you want at least
do a good performance and maybe Tom
Phyllis will think of me for another
role in the future so that I went in
with that mindset you know we'll just
see what happens and and just I just
remembered Todd Phillips couldn't stop
laughing and I think literally the next
day or two I got the part and again keep
in mind we did not know the hangover
would be The Hangover at that time I
remember telling my wife like I think I
just film the funniest movie ever I
asked him told my way I don't know if
you'll like it I think this might be
like a guys comedy I don't know and then
and I remember we watched an early
screening with friends and family and
Trey and my wife the moment where
Bradley Cooper says Tracy we [ __ ] up
like boom Tran laughed she just could
not stop laughing she
got it she got what it was all about and
it was off to the races I did about at
least 35 to 40 takes I mean jumping out
naked from different angles and
different things and that was my idea to
be naked in the movie it was just I just
felt like when he jumps out of the trunk
and it said he had slacks on that's like
well if he just jumps out like fully
naked it'd just be shocking and I do
remember I even said I actually talked
it over with my wife I said like I I
think you know I want to do this naked
so I actually ran it by her before I ran
it by Todd Phillips and then and she
said and I quote it'll be the feel-good
movie of the summer because every guy
will go home feeling good about
themselves and that's my wife the mother
of my two kids so what so when I pitched
it to tide to be naked in the movie he
was like and he's got a very deep voice
you know what the Toby toys that was his
actual words and he made me sign a
agreement to be naked in the movie that
this was my idea and I'm doing this
voluntarily but also that I couldn't
change my mind so he just knew it would
be the perfect moment midpoint in the
movie after they had already seen Mike
Tyson there I saw the tiger what could
be worse it was like Oh what what the
hell is this going on
Chow is John the sky is just jumped out
naked and just beat up three people with
a crowbar it's like it just added to
what was already a suspenseful movie to
me is it's there is just a lifelong bond
I think that will that that will that
will last forever on celluloid you know
it's yeah it's oh it was a magical time
and it just it just it just changed my
life forever I mean the moment the
hangover came out I was starting to get
instantly recognized
money - big rock in Mojave Desert at
dawn I was at an ATM withdrawing some
cash and this guy's looking at me from a
sedan with the window half half cracked
open not a paparazzi just staring at me
withdraw some cash I'm uncomfortable
staring at withdraw some cash staring at
me the light turns green and he goes to
the little [ __ ] like that that I
get that all the time
that's like everyday for me now every
day community six seasons and still
waiting on that movie I remember Dan
actually had seen an outtake of knocked
up where Judd Apatow gave me a free take
he wrote the part of Senor Chang with me
in mind kind of he liked that place of
authority with a little bit of unhinged
I would do takes on community that was
completely unhinged and improvisational
contrary to popular belief I mean you
actually don't him you don't improvise
much and on television in general I
didn't really know that I was like
community was my first TV series I
remember the first my first moment is
Senor Chang where it's like why do you
teach Spanish and that is all mostly
improvised well I'll tell you why I
teach Spanish it is none of your
business okay now I don't want to have
any conversations about what a
mysterious inscrutable man I am I am a
Spanish genius in espanol my nickname is
El Tigre chino dan told me later he was
just furious because those are his words
carefully written words after I realized
that's not how you do it in television
and that's not how Dan wants it pretty
soon thereafter I stopped improvising on
that show and it was at that point where
I developed just true confidence as an
actor I knew who I was and because even
though I was doing movies there were
there were small parts in these movies
and I never had formal acting training
ado cuz I dime
you know turning down yeah Duke School
of Acting so I always thought of
community as my conservatory Baz burgers
is the gift that keeps on giving player
recurring on that show dr. Yap and Loren
Bouchard he he wrote the part of dr. Yap
from with me in mind and and I love
doing I love doing animation I love
doing voiceover is a patient in here
earlier and I accidentally stuck a
needle through his cheek just I hate
mondays in some of the movies I've done
like turbo Despicable Me 2 Penguins of
Madagascar I'm usually by myself I'm I
remember the first time I did Baz
burgers it was with the entire cast and
that was first time I've done animation
like that which I love just feeding off
of everybody's energy I really quite
liked having everybody but you know
they're you know and I try to you know
would like to do more of that if
possible because you really feed off
that energy really envisioned the whole
scene and but the thing about Bob's
Burgers that I love is again much like
Dan Harmon the writing is so crisp you
know and I always do it no matter what I
mean I it's been through every phase of
my career like community hangover movies
doctor Kent I just did an episode this
past season I'll do it whenever they ask
me no matter how busy I am dr. Ken I'll
be honest that was my proudest
accomplishment because I created that
show it's based on my life um he had you
show that five Asian American series
regulars on a broadcast show that was
based on my life working as a father as
a husband as as a doctor and I was in
the writers room every day you know I
remember dr. ken for anything but if
anything else
if community made me a better actor dr.
ken made me a better writer
I would definitely help out with scripts
and help break story and help give notes
on editing and time cuts and time notes
by the end of the series I was doing not
only the editing but I remember the
showrunner went on BK
for a couple of weeks and he trusted me
enough to do the sound mixing I mean
that's like real producer stuff what I
like it actually really helped me out as
an actor because my improv is just very
much just you know for himself and just
I just I just throw out the kitchen sink
and now when I improvise I really pick
and choose my spots I'm a little bit
more precise I don't need to be
gratuitous and just show everybody hey
you looking what I can do you know and I
feel even more mature that's as an actor
and that comes actually from writing
crazy rich ages
when dr. ken got cancelled I John Chu
call me call me for gave me the part and
and I'm a big fan of the books by by
Kevin Kwan
so within moments of that cancellation
I'm on a flight to Singapore and
Malaysia shooting that movie in the very
first scene I think I was just I think I
was processing what what had just
happened on my own show and it was so
therapeutic nice to meet you too chu
cuckoo could you you crazy rich Asians
was another full-circle moment because
it was always a dream of mine to be a
part of a movie like The Joy Luck Club
and all Asian American cast made by a
Hollywood studio and we're the first
coincidentally or maybe not so
coincidentally it was the first all
Asian American cast in a major Hollywood
studio film since The Joy Luck Club 25
years prior and it becomes like the
biggest romantic comedy in a decade it
becomes a number-one movie three weeks
in a row I knew who is a great I knew
even while filming it I knew it would be
a great movie because I I loved the
source material and the cast led by
Constance Wu Henry Goulding Michelle
Yeoh and Aquafina
I even more are filming I knew it I knew
would be a good movie so I had no doubt
in my mind I was just hoping people who
weren't Asian would see it i I did not I
did not know if we would cross over
it did with with and then some friends
of mine who are Asian American
filmmakers and writers and directors
they're getting their projects greenlit
by major studios by broadcast networks
it actually has made an impact it has
moved the needle in the business and
just to be a part of it a small part of
it is it's a very big deal you know and
also you know I have two daughters Alexa
and Zoey they're 11 years old and they
have these wonderful role models to look
up to I'm quoting Nikko Santos who's in
the movie of superstore and he says this
kind of movie rising tides lifts all
boats and that's you know I whenever I
think of crazy rich Asians I think of
that masked singer the mass singer is
the most popular like competition show
in Korea and in Thailand it also happens
to be my mom's favorite show
coming from Korean background and when I
got offered the show I was like well
it's not really it was not my thing
you know at all and and my mom was like
she showed me she sent me links of the
show is she's like it's it's my it's my
favorite show you you got to do this and
I was just kind of like okay this is not
my thing and and I and I ended up just
leap of faith like my mom was really was
like adamant and we did this promo for
for Fox Network you're like hi I'm
so-and-so hi I'm Robin I'm Jenna and it
comes to me I'd leave a look at the
camera like I Alice you don't know what
I'm doing here on the show I'm literally
the dumbest guy live I don't know
anything about anything
and there could be these amazing singers
in these amazing costumes and you the
whole point is to guess who this is it's
like a combo of a wreckin Otto what's my
line concentration it's like all like
for like different genres and I'm
literally just getting paid to guess
stupidly I'm so freaking confused right
now I don't know who I am you know I'm
like like I literally would do takes
like this you know I think I know who
this is Senator Chuck Schumer welcome to
the masked singer so like all my tastes
like completely I was just having fun
just having a laugh and just being
completely stupid and and also hearing
some amazing
voices and when you really get into like
these are these are singers who are or
maybe performers who aren't known for
singers you don't you don't know who
they are
[Music]
it's kind of addictive to get into
guessing in the art like I had my wife
and kids come to a taping and everyone
is into it and like even my manager who
like managers for little secret like
when managers go there their client says
you know they don't want to be there
they just there to show moral support
and like anybody you know like my
manager went to every single taping he
was like who do you like he'd be texting
me like while the show is going is it is
it so-and-so and so-and-so and like it's
like dude I thought you already left my
Netflix special it's it's one of my
favorite things I've ever done again I
knew it was all organic it was something
that I didn't even know if I wanted to
do stand-up full-time I just had a lot
of daylight on my calendar after dr. ken
ended and I was just Restless and I was
like you know maybe I'll just try
stand-up and see how that works I did a
couple spot gigs and in clubs in LA and
and I just fell in love it again with
stand-up I'd done stand-up comedy for 17
years prior to the first hangover so it
was a lot of full circle involved maybe
it's the doctor pardon me I always
compartmentalize a fit like oh community
was my acting school maybe dr. Ken's my
fellowship you know and maybe my Netflix
special is my post-grad work I don't
know it's like I do I do find myself
like academically compartmentalizing a
lot of my work it's my own way of
finding a deeper meaning to what I do
than just you know just fame and fortune
you know you you want you do this
because you love it and you do it
because it matters you know and it feeds
here for lack of a better word if these
are soul you know this is